governor and un Ambassador and 2024
presidential Republican presidential
candidate Nikki Haley you know it seems
that the economy gets the most play
because that impacts people's lives
daily but peace and prosperity
historically uh Drive elections um we
now have conflicts we have war in Europe
we have war in the Middle East uh we
have Iran sponsoring Terror uh you know
in the case of the hoodies they're the
ones that have been providing all their
military equipment their proxy war
against Saudi Arabia the missiles being
fired into Israel you know so I guess it
raises the obvious question about
foreign policy you know what would the
Nikki Haley Doctrine be on all three of
these
issues first of all Sean I mean I it is
a constant topic of conversation that
comes up with voters here in Iowa um
we've also seen it in New Hampshire
people are worried they see those War
those Wars and they're worried about
what this means we should always be
focused on National Security and
prevention of War that's what Joe
Biden's missed the reason all this has
happened is because he's been too slow
and too weak on everything we saw it
from Afghanistan we saw it in the fact
that that Putin surrounded Ukraine a
whole year before and he did nothing we
see it now with Iran they smell blood in
the water and so what they're doing is
they're taking advantage of every
situation because they know Joe isn't
and what bothers me even more than that
I've told people what keeps me up at
night is what happens between now and
election day because you just showed
that clip of Joe Biden it didn't even
feel like he knew where he
was yeah it's chilling I mean when I
first started pointing this out which
was in the election of 2020 you know I
was actually excoriated by some for
stating the obvious that he was weak and
frail and a cognitive mess all right but
more specifically what should America's
role on the world stage be you know Joe
Biden is you know he wants over what 200
million billion dollars going to the
Ukraine war that's that to me looks like
a proxy war between us and Russia uh Joe
is pressuring Israel you know for a
ceasefire and if I was President I'd be
telling Israel go win your War you're a
victim of Terror if you extrapolate the
population out of Israel and compare it
to the US that would be the equivalent
of losing 40,000 Americans on October
seven my advice to them would be to to
beat back Hamas in the South uh
Hezbollah in the north uh to take on
Iran and take out their refineries and
and probably their nuclear sites if they
want peace in the region for a long
period of time I think they've got to
they've got to win the war and secure
their Nation because they're surrounded
by a lot of
enemies well the first thing I'll tell
you is we should never give cash to any
country country Friend or Foe because
you can't follow it you can't hold it
accountable you know take these one at a
time you look at Ukraine here's a
pro-american freedom loving country who
was invaded by a thug half a million
people have died and been wounded
because of Putin but why should America
care about Ukraine that's a legitimate
question to ask the problem is Biden and
no one else is telling the American
people the truth we know and I saw this
every day at the UN dictators Thugs and
terrorists tell us exactly what they're
going to do they're amazingly
transparent Hamas said they were going
to go into Israel they did China said
they were going to take Hong Kong we
watched it Russia said they were going
to invade Ukraine it happened China says
Taiwan is next we better believe them
Russia said once they take Ukraine
Poland and the baltics are next those
are NATO countries that puts America at
War this is about preventing War it's
always been about preventing war and if
we were to support Ukraine with just
equipment and ammunition no cash
that's only 32% of our defense budget
the Europeans have paid more than that
and they should it's their neighborhood
when it comes to Israel they're the tip
of the spear when it comes to defeating
terrorism they're a bright spot in a
tough neighborhood it has never been
that Israel needs America it has always
been America needs Israel and when you
look at the fact that on that terrible
day of October 7th when they beheaded
those people and burned those babies
alive and took those girls from the
concert and raped them and dragged their
naked bodies through the streets of Gaza
what did they say death to Israel death
to America and if you look back on that
horrific Dayan of October 7th that was
Putin's birthday Putin had hit rock
bottom we know that because he had lost
87% of his fighting force that started
the war they'd raised the draft age to
65 they were getting drones from Iran
and missiles from North Korea who's the
happiest person in the world right now
it's Putin why because us and the West
took took their eyes off of Ukraine and
moved it to Israel Putin never called
Netanyahu after that not for 10 days you
know who he did call he called Hamas
invited them to Russia they came the
next day and they held hands as friends
Russia China and Iran are bound together
in an Unholy Alliance because they hate
Freedom they hate democracy and more
than anything they hate America I call
it the next it is a new axis of Evil
there's no no doubt about it you know
Joe Biden did not demand that Europe
protect their own continent first they
should have put the bulk of money Joe
Biden then put handcuffs on zinsky and
said oh you can't take migs from Poland
they offered him 28 migs at the time
then he said oh and you can't use
cluster bombs well at that point we're
throwing our money down the drain
because Joe's not allowing Ukraine and
they they have fought valiantly and and
I I agree with you Putin's a thug and a
murderer and a dictator um but Joe Biden
put hand cuffs on their ability to fight
the war uh as it relates to is exactly
right you're exactly right and on Israel
all he needed to say is Go win your war
and stop the behind the scenes we has
one message publicly one message
privately all my sources in Israel say
he's putting pressure on Israel not to
have a ceasefire not and not continue
the conflict no the message should be
beat back the terrorists that were
raping murdering and killing your
citizens in in the dark and night and
Joe Biden doesn't seem to have that
philosophy and he's allowed Iran and and
Russia to get rich because of his energy
policies all of that is impactful to to
the entire
world that's exactly right and that's
why our friends don't trust us at this
point and that's why our enemies don't
fear us that's why Joe Biden needs to be
out of office and that's why I intend to
get America strong and proud again all
right how do you think you're going to
do
Monday I think we're going to have a
strong showing on Monday it's cold it's
really cold but I think we're going to
have a strong showing on Monday yeah I'm
leaving the warm weather of my new state
to go to 20° below WEA uh uh 20° below
zero weather wow uh anyway I applaud all
of for being out there layer up it's
cold oh I'm layering up I might even get
toe and hand warmers on top of it uh
appreciate you being with us uh Governor
thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else